you
I'm responsible for all of the sound
during during production so I'll be the
person that looks after crewing of the
film for all of the different units that
we might have during production I'll be
responsible for recording on the main
unit and deciding how the production
sound is is recorded my role in
production is is merely to capture their
performances if there's actors there's
effects there's whatever is happening on
set I have to get a good recording of
that first sound which then gets
provided to my colleagues in
post-production who will assemble the
final track from that but also to record
things within the environment sound
effects that you think will be useful
editorially or creatively at the end the
sound process there's been a tutorial
before I receive the sound but you're
ultimately with a colleague typically
there's one or two of you involved the
responsibility is to deliver the final
soundtrack for the film so it would be a
combination of typically music dialogue
and sound effects first thing is that
I'll get a script I'll read a script and
I'll I'll do some work on that breaking
it down deciding how you know what what
it means to me for sound what needs to
be thought about I'll then have meetings
with the director and we'll talk about
what his vision is about the film then
probably will start to scout locations
in a scanning locations is a valuable
time that's when you're all together
you're together with the DP the director
the production designer key people the
film and you start to talk about what's
going to happen on each of those
locations or those sets and the director
will talk about shots he wants to do
what he's got in mind the only thing
that's consistent day-to-day generally
is is breakfast even the lunches aren't
always predictable but the the work is
always different after three decades in
the job there's a lot of things that we
do that we've done before but it's
always different every day is a is a new
new invention of our work the shooting
multi-camera now
generally so whereas in the past you'd
have one camera there'll be a frame size
and you could work out whether you could
get your microphone in or not and where
to put radio mics but with multi camera
you've got to usually go to cover the
whole scene and then people actors for
their performance they usually want to
overlap their dialogue and again you
have to find ways through of making that
work both technically and for the actors
you can't just say don't do this don't
do that no gravity is a completely
different film no gravity is you know
starting again and we used a lot you
know pretty much all the equipment that
was available to us but a lot of it was
custom built so you see a microphone on
her face that's a practical microphone
that's a microphone we use we took a
standard very small microphone and we we
molded the end of it to a look right but
also to help us to keep out any noise
from outside so undoing Davis when we
could we would record using two
microphones for them for the music
particularly when he goes into the
Columbia recording session we wanted a
microphone that looked right for the
period and sounded right for the period
and we managed to get a variety of you
47s which we used for recording
recording the scene but the scene in The
Gaslight they wanted a period microphone
on stage which was a dynamic I think a
sure as age 55
but the prop mic we had wasn't
functional so Randy and I disassembled
it and hit a Shep's inside of it and
then we recorded the you know almost all
of those tracks on our little hidden
ship's microphone my responsibility is
dialogue and music was my colleague I
have the sound effects the Folies which
are the footsteps and all the small side
effects we break down the mixing process
into two defined sections one is the
premix section and I have to take all
the dialogue which is recorded on
location and any other dialogue that
might be recorded like we call it ADR
which is dialogue that's recorded in the
studio which is replacement dialogue you
might need it because
technical problems onset on the next
process which is the final mix the
decision makers can basically say they
want the dialogue loud or quiet Turtles
coming out left speaker coming out the
right speaker more bassy so we do lots
of very technical things at that stage
removing camera whistle lighting harm or
lots of you know and background traffic
we might want to take let's see we're
doing a period drama with kind of
modern-day traffic in the background
when I started you'd have one real
surreal recorder and you might have to
boom mics out you'd hardly ever use
personal radio mics you know everything
is nonlinear it's all computer-based
there's no tape to deal with and tape
provided it's on level of noise so there
are those technical things that have
changed on the post-production side
again is changed enormously when I
started you physically run the sound
with a this is me doing this or a mime
of the of the pick sing and you'd find
where the sound you wanted was he mark
it with a bit of china graph you put
that against the the picture and you
might combine it with one or two sounds
on top of that but often you'd have to
guess what they sound like together
because you sometimes only could hear
two things at once and now on Rush when
we put all their tracks together since
the whole team the other effects guys
the other sound designer guys doing the
atmosphere is all the feet there's I
mean I've to know it was hundreds of
tracks hundreds of hundreds of tracks
and you can listen to them together as
well you know the question of people
always ask me is what you know what do
you need to succeed at being a sound
mixer I think I would always say be a
filmmaker that specializes in sound
rather than the sound person who
specialized in film a keen interest in
all aspects of filmmaking I think is
essential for any particular department
see what other departments are available
that's my first advice then I recommend
working with people who know what
they're doing
experiences everything but if you can
share in somebody else's experience and
it saves you a lot of time making the
mistakes for yourself well with as many
different sound crews as you can
and definitely to work in both the
production sound mixing side and
post-production side even if you're sure
that you just want to be a location
sound mixer even if you know but I don't
want to sit in a room with a lot of
computers designing sound it's so useful
to know the other side of the job you
have to embrace the whole of film you
have to be interested in film sound is
an important part of the film but it is
part of the film you can't think of it
in isolation